when you meet inverse trig functions
which will happen next year
okay when you meet invest trig functions
this
process that we're going to go through
is intensely important
okay so even though it starts off pretty
pedestrian and simple
it has some implications for later which
is why i'm making a big deal out of it
okay i'll undo this question first
because fn is easier and then we'll move
over that one
find the range of half times three t
minus one if the range of t
is that okay it's actually very very
simple there are a few different ways to
do it
i think the most long-term useful way to
do it
is to start with this inequality right
this statement
minus one is less than or equal to t
which is less than three
okay you use that as your starting point
and then you modify it you adjust it
until such a point that you arrive at
this okay
this is not hard right watch there's a
few different things that have been done
to this i'm just going to go from the
inside
and outwards okay so i'm going to start
by there's a 3t there and i've only got
one
so i'm just going to multiply everything
through by 3. that'll become negative 3
that'll be 3t and that'll be 9. okay
it's a positive number there's nothing
wrong
now i've got 3t but i want a 3t minus 1.
so i'm going to subtract 1 from
everything right so this is going to
become
negative 4 3t minus 1 and that's going
to become
8 and then i'm almost there i just have
to multiply everything by half
okay so this is going to become negative
2 there's
the function that i was interested in
and there's your answer okay so it pops
out super simple
right now it becomes a little trickier
when you come to this kind of question
okay
for instance let's just see does it work
trying to do the same kind of thing
right well if i start with this
okay can i simply say well if this is
t and i want to the power of that does
this work
yes it does does it work
let's just let's just evaluate it shall
we 2 to the power of negative one is a
half
there's two of the t in there and that's
h does
it work okay now how can you know for
sure because remember when we're having
a look at
you know if i if i say this right and
then i take the reciprocals
right what happens to the inequality
well it goes the other way
right and the way we can know is not
because it's some arbitrary rule
not because i just tell you that you can
but because you can actually try this
and see what happens
right so for instance let's have a look
at this thing
we know what this looks like it's just
to the power of whatever it's a
different
variable but who cares so
right if here's our t-axis instead of
calling it
x right then this axis we usually call y
but it's just two to the power of t
that's all that is okay
so what does this look like it's just
your standard old exponential
like so what's our intercept here one
and then of course you've got
an asymptote happening there which would
be more accurate you would hope but
that's
to the t equals zero
okay which can't exist it doesn't
actually exist which is why it's an
asymptote okay
now now think right here's my t-axis
happening in here
right and i'm limited between negative
one and three so where's negative one
negative one's like there so if i place
that scale
then i go one two three so there's that
value
okay so this is where i'm limited
horizontally
that's what that means this question is
where am i limited therefore
vertically and the answer is you can see
it visually right
where does this correspond to yeah
that's inclusive
and that's not inclusive
okay so here's my horizontal domain
right so here's my vertical range from
this value
which we know to be a half because we
just worked it out
all the way up until this value which is
8. so in fact
this does work just fine okay now i'm
just going to give a caution you're not
going to meet them just yet okay
but this this trick right you have to be
cautious with it
okay for instance you can probably
imagine if i said well
if i have this right
what would the range of sine t b
or cos t or tan t can i just simply
apply sine to everything or cos to
everything or tan or whatever
it's bounded by you have to be careful
you have to be careful this trick it
doesn't just simply
work okay but here you can see
why it works because that's what this
means and half
and eight are just the boundaries